sweat I sweat you sweat will sweat well
some men's with a little bit more than
others right but still we all sweat and
it sucks stinks it stains clothes and he
just sucks well unless you use the right
deodorant especially for you young guys
out there you have to develop a habit of
putting on deodorant or antiperspirant
as soon as you finish the shower why
well then you'll never find yourself in
that embarrassing situation where you're
at a place and people remember you as
that guy that's thinks all right so what
is the best antiperspirant or deodorant
out there for men well that's what we're
gonna talk about in this video so let's
get to it I have a dream hey guys if
this is your first time here on my
channel welcome I'm Daniel and so
they're subscribing and also clicking
that notification belt so you won't miss
any of the next vids now let's start
with the first deodorant
dov stain defense antiperspirant now
doesn't present a lot of their men's
products over the years if you look at
the quality and the low price and the
rant burst brain is no different it's
very good and it protects you against
those ugly yellow stains that you really
don't want it smells fresh and it is
also good to use if you have sensitive
skin all right let's move on to the next
one
the underarm deodorant stick now this is
one of the best ones out there on a
market why well because it actually
works the way that they advertise it not
only that but it has organic ingredients
that detox your body and nourish your
skin so basically it's a natural organic
deodorant that works great a lot of free
in the video description below so you
can check it out it's got over 2000 of a
happy customer reviews from people like
menu that tried it out already and
actually give you a 30-day money-back
guarantee if it is not the best
deodorant that you've ever used now that
says a lot all right let's move on to
the next one all right we had the last
one and the last one is my favorite
Nivea invisible black and white this guy
it's never ever let me down it's an
antiperspirant and so it will help you
to sweat less and it will protect you
from those ugly yellow and white stains
on your clothes that you don't want I
usually get three of them at the same
time so then I'll know I'm set for the
next few months and I don't need to
worry about getting any new
antiperspirant so this guy smells good
it is cheap and it works great a lot of
unity description check it out there
like the video put a thumbs up subscribe
and I'll see you in the next video
cheers guys
[Music]
you